I just spent the last five days trying
to give this room the biggest glow up
this is how it looked before and no
I'm not responsible for that okay
this is just how it looked when we bought it
not to frighten you if you've been following for a while
but we moved in 11 months ago
I know what the actual fk right
and for the last 11 months
my first born has been calling this his bedroom
and he's about to turn 12
so for his birthday I wanted to surprise him
with a brand new bedroom
we stripped everything out plastered
sanded and primed every surface in the bedroom
my husband put up some panelling
and then we painted until we could no longer feel our arms
then I cleaned the windows and shampooed
the carpets and that was day four done
I let the carpet dry overnight and then we came back on day five
which was the funnest day of all
because today we get to make it actually a bedroom
my son didn't ask for much
but he did ask for a bigger bed
and here's me pretending to put up a shelf
which I actually had nothing to do with
I put a 15 dollar Minecraft poster in a cheap
frame and now it looks like art
hung some sheers and these windows will
also have some roller blinds
but they're not ready yet
Re-used these guitar holders
which we had from our old house
and I found this light shade for 13 dollars
and I reckon it looks a damn sight better than what it was
my son's use these drawers all of his life
which my dad painted for me when I was a baby
and we installed some second hand lights
which we got from my in laws
and after an extremely busy five days this is how it turned out
I love that the majority of the things in this room were things we already had
I painted my 20 year old side table and that lamp in part one
and the wall panelling and the paint we had left over from another project
and I reused his favourite things and sentimental items for styling
The teenage years can be fkn brutal
so I wanted to create a calming sanctuary for him
that reflects who he is as a person
but also one that he can put his own stamp on
and that will grow with him through the next chapter
and hopefully if he likes it
he might even keep it clean